herzlich willkommen zum dritten thema
des heutigen abends es gibt ja den den
schönen spruch nichts ist so mächtig wie
eine idee deren zeit gekommen ist leider
gottes werden manchmal auch ideen
mächtig deren zeit lieber nie gekommen
wäre und eine solche idee ist die quote
man kann ihr kaum entkommen momentan die
frauenquote vor allem die sogenannte
frauenquote sogar die cdu scheint wild
entschlossen sich umzubenennen in q3 in
die deutsche quoten union zumindest
lassen darauf vorbereitungen zum
grundsatzprogramm schließen und jetzt
ganz frisch hat sich die eu darauf
geeinigt die eu eine frauenquote in den
aufsichtsräten börsennotierter
unternehmen einzuführen 40 prozent
sollen müssen frauen seien am 20 26
alternativ 33 prozent frauen zusammen
und aufsichtsrat und vorstand eine
frauenquote ist liberal sie setzt frauen
dem verdacht aus der eu gerecht ist sie
wäre nur aufgrund ihres geschlechtes in
diese position gekommen seien eben diese
typischen quotenfrauen sie ist eine
anmaßung in diesem fall der staat
regiert in die unternehmen hinein
schreibt den vor aufgrund äußerliche
merkmale ihre kompetenzen aufzufüllen
und ich frag mich natürlich auch wo
bitteschön ende stand das bei mir
gegenüber wird ein haus gebaut ich
beobachte dass jeden tag ich sehe nur
männer müssen jetzt den letzten
bauschritte dort von frauen gemacht
werden weil wir eine frauenquote auf dem
bau haben oder umgekehrt ich kaufe mir
morgens meine brötchen und ich werde
seit acht jahren nur von sehr sehr
freundlichen frauen bedient wenn ich
meine brötchen kaufen brauchen wir da
nun eine männerquote wie sieht es aus
bei hebammen brauchen wir demnächst auch
vielleicht eine quote für rothaarige
verschiedene oder für platzen nein eine
quote ist immer ungerecht aufgrund
äußerer merkmale kann man keinen
kompetenzen zu weisen keine talente
verordnen weg mit diesen mumpitz wir
brauchen keine quote
donnerwetter
von ihr dass sie die reben und ich kann
sie nicht verstehen ganz ehrlich weil
wir haben 22 prozent der frauen der
mitglieder frauen so und wir haben schon
eine 30-prozentige quote er wollte mir
50 event ja an der 30 und die kriegen
werden kreisverbänden verwenden schon
nicht mehr voll weil zu wenig da sind
und darum finde es ungerecht und die
frauen die wir jetzt in den positionen
haben die sind die sind richtig klasse
die sind richtig gut und die kommt zu
mir sagt jetzt irgendwie eine quotenfrau
ich hab auch mal alleine geschafft und
das hat einfach völlig wie sie sagen
ungerecht und insofern erwarte ich
natürlich auch in der cdu das ist nicht
wieder von oben kommt der praxis in der
basis diskutieren also für die
abstimmung sind würde die fdp vorschlägt
zum beispiel auf jeden fall
im betrieb ich habe nur frauen bei mir
die frauen entscheiden selbst und ich
arbeite in die die arbeiten wirklich
perfekt exzellent also insofern an der
arbeit der frauen wir brauchen mehr
frauen nur die quote ändert ja nichts
wir müssen die formate ändern dass wir
vielleicht frau die zu hause ihre kinder
versorgen wenn es dann halt nicht mehr
den ehegatten irgendwie geteilt wird
dass wir andere formate wählen damit die
sich auch engagieren können aber eine
quote ändert ja nicht die
rahmenbedingungen aber letztlich cdu und
diese debatte aufdrängen warum wird die
so geführt ja weil sie natürlich diese
auseinandersetzung will sie möchte
einfach wieder aufwachen merken sie also
wir wollen nicht mehr so eine moralisch
ja es wird natürlich eine moral der
filesharer so und und wir wollen
natürlich auch alle mit gewissen der
volkspartei und deshalb verschiedene
einstellungen und für uns ist für mich
ist einfach wichtig dass wir das in der
basis diskutieren weil so einfach
entscheiden können sie nicht so ich
frage sie einmal im herrn meier ob er
jetzt auch das einfach unterschreibt das
plädoyer wie ihr sehen sie dass in der
frage wurde war ein shirt ja schon wir
können darüber jetzt so lustig reden und
darüber lachen und ja es ist nicht
schlimm mit den frauen aber die war
schon wenn man sich den deutschen
vorstände anguckt ist ein trauerspiel ja
also zunächst erstmal muss man
feststellen dass diverse teams besser
funktionieren also wenn er frauen
menschen aus von unten und ja ich glaube
schon dass das hat man eben auch ein
verband aber es effizienter ist als
quasi eine quasi
zusammenrottung von nur gleichen
erfahrungswerten so deswegen gibt es
grundsätzlich
glaube ich gute gründe dafür frauen zu
fördern
genauso wie andere
ethnien aber nicht über
eine quote sondern über leistung das ist
ja der grundansatz und man kann gerade
in strukturen die vielleicht wir bemühen
uns ja auch mehr frauen zu fördern in
der fdp das machen wir auf freiwilliger
basis das ist eine führungsaufgabe
christian als bundesvorsitzender das
sehr deutlich auch formuliert und
angenommen deswegen erhöhen
wir haben wir haben aber wir haben im
bundesvorstand mittlerweile eine quote
von glaube ich 45 46 prozent frauen und
zwar ohne verpflichtende quote sondern
weil es genug
nachwuchs politikerinnen genug
interessenten gibt wohl wir haben das
ist ein punkt da wollen wir da wollen
wir zusammen irgendwo etwas wagen was
wir bisher nicht
und als partei haben wir in
frauenanteil ich glaube von 21 prozent
das kann besser werden der ist momentan
glaube ich sogar ein bisschen gesungen
weil sehr viele männer in die partei
eingetreten sind in den letzten jahren
das freut uns auf der einen seite dass
sehr viele neue parteimitglieder zu uns
gekommen sind auf der anderen seite
heißt das dass wir bei frauen noch
stärker werden müssen aber das ist eine
freiwilligkeit aber unternehmen was mich
jetzt gerade aktuell weil damit weiter
gerade wenn ich meine wahl so dass also
der staat oder ein staatenverbund sei
yahoo musst in deiner inneren struktur
eine quote ist könnt ihr später auch mal
eine männerquote sein wenn ihr eine frau
und wenn er genauso falsch muss eine
quote machen damit du ohne
strafzahlungen ein geschädigter
vollkommen weg ist dann finden sie 33
prozent für aufsichtsrat und vorstand
bei börsennotierten unternehmen so viel
was heisst so viel das ist jetzt relativ
ich finde einfach die vorstellung dass
also ein staatenverbund in dem fall ja
auch mit der kommission die auch nur
mittelbar ermächtigt ist vom vom wahl
folgt der einzelnen nationalstaaten dass
sie also so intensiv hineinregiert im
binnenverhältnis man muss natürlich
darauf achten dass niemand diskriminiert
wird das thema aufgrund seines alters
seines geschlechts seiner herkunft
seines glaubens was auch immer das jeder
grundsätzlich alles werden kann das ist
gleichberechtigung aber nicht
hergestellt die bereitstellung mädchen
prinzip das was der schmitt sucht das
mädchen prinzip wie männer suchen männer
und
möchte ich gerne die runde geben es gibt
ja schmitt sucht schmidtchen prinzip es
kam hatte ich hab ich auch eigenen
wikipedia-eintrag also sie sich vor mir
erfunden dass man oft menschen fördert
die am gleich sind sie würden jemanden
fördern jetzt nicht der blonde sind
weiblich ist wie ich laut im prinzip
sollen jemand der aussieht wie der
kleine alexander merkel könnte ich für
mich aus wenn das schmidt so noch
mädchen prinzip aber besteht und man
also eher fördert menschen am
ähnlichsten also eher dohrendorf würde
sich jemanden suchen wir auch so in
janka trägt und die haare zurück gegeben
hat und ich würde mir blondine suchen
die ähnlich ist zu mir dann haben wir
eine indirekte quote weil dann wird ja
wenn männer oben sind fördern die auch
wieder männer und dann dass ich wird es
verstreuten ich würde es beschreiben ist
ich glaube auch nicht dass ein mann oder
eine frau jemand gute sich entgehen
lässt nur weil er an das andere
geschlecht hat also das kann ich mir
nicht also ich schon gar nicht mehr und
ich bin auch nicht
erfolgreich weil ich müde wurde
gefördert wurde sondern einfach weil ich
es kann ja ich habe immer mein ding
gemacht ich hatte drei brüder und ich
habe mir nie da ein thema draus gemacht
wäre hier mehr was zu sagen hat oder
nicht oder wer stärker ist oder ich ich
meine und es gibt genug frauen dies die
sich durchsetzen und es gibt immer mehr
aber es ich fänd es jetzt auch falsch
ich meine ich habe auch freundinnen die
in vorstände wollten und die dann gesagt
haben die die typen lassen uns einfach
nicht rein die ball an die tür zu und
wollen unter sich bleiben und die war
auch trinkfest und die war tüchtig und
alle sie sagt ich nicht
aber ich meine gute gedanke da geht eben
durch sehr sehr viele bereichen durch
alles muss kotierte wäre es bleibt ihr
gleich beim geschlecht hängen dann muss
man auch irgendwelche heer künftig
rotieren und vielleicht noch andere
vorlieben und das finde ich einfach
problematisch weil der mensch hat seine
eigene events gehabt jetzt geht nur um
frauen oder männer es ging ja manchmal
andere andere andere ideen zu binden
sie denkt ist die frage wie macht man
schluss und das zeigt ihr dass das ganze
system einer starren quote halt am ende
in die sackgasse führt wurde am ende
würde das bedeuten dass wir die
gesellschaft dann
eins zu eins abdecken müssen in
jeglichen lebenssachverhalt ob
vorstandspositionen
aufsichtsratspositionen parteien
parlamenten des angeblich für solches
sagen das geht nicht deswegen sind wir
auch auf den sich alle dagegen das
abbrechen ja aber das wir dass wir in
deutschland auch schon einiges erreicht
haben ich will jetzt nicht wie das thema
vorgängerregierung aufmachen aber wir
haben ja auch in deutschland bereits in
deutschland bereits quasi eine
entsprechende
sanfte quote dass wir heute das
familien- und frauenministerin heute
auch glaube ich zu
diesem kompromiss von der europäischen
ebene
sich geäußert dass das für deutschland
gar nicht mehr relevant ist weil wir
halt schon entsprechend geringer eine
geringere quote haben dennoch ist es
richtig dass wir aufpassen müssen was
auf der europäischen ebene von der
europäischen union an verpflichtenden
richtlinien verordnungs werken